bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on a
l'impression que les tractations tourne
surtout autour et non pas sur l'accord
en tant que tels notamment avec cette
demande par l'iran d'une levée des
sanctions américaines qu'en pensez vous
je pense c'est aussi un peu paradoxal
comme l'a dit dans votre reportage ont
l'impression que tout le monde est
d'accord pour que les états unis
reviennent dans la corde 2015 qu'ils ont
quitté en mai 2018 mais avant qu'on a
l'impression que est-ce que c'est
simplement des questions de forme qui
fait le premier pas ou est ce qu'il ya
des choses plus profondes derrière je
pense que du côté de l'iran je pense
qu'à position est assez claire élise les
états unis ont pu tel accord en mai 2018
mais ils on remettra réinstaller remis
en place des sanctions mais s'il voulait
recommencer depuis le début mai que les
états unis reviennent dans l'accord
annule toutes les sanctions qu'ils
auraient imposé en 2018 et c'est beau on
recommence à discuter du côté américain
premièrement il ya l'idée non c'est
l'iran qui doit faire le premier geste
que l'iran a pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour sortir de l'accord après la
sortie des étés ligue d'accord donc
c'est déjà un peu un peu étonnant on va
dire deuxièmement ils veulent pas lever
toutes les sanctions très clairement on
le sent bien et surtout à mon avis un
problème qui fâche les iraniens c'est
qu'ils veulent dire ok on discute on
discute d'un nouvel accord dans l'accord
sur le balistique iranien et d'un accord
sur la politique régionale de l'iran et
je pense même où d'après ce que j'ai
compris
même à l'intérieur de l'administration
maiden ya des désaccords il ya ceux qui
disent d'ailleurs il faut revenir dans
l'accord 2015 et ceux qui disent non
il faut ouvrir de nouvelles négociations
donc c'est pas simplement une question
de qui commence comme s'ils voulaient y
est je pense que des désaccords sur quel
est l'objet de la discussion
téhéran entre autres a par la voix du
ministre des affaires étrangères
mohammed javad dit arif affiche en tout
cas c'est ces conditions sur cette levée
sans condition des sanctions américaines
est ce que on peut parler d'un camouflet
pour l'administration maiden non mais en
plus ciblées quand vous dites levé sans
condition les suivirent ce serait la
france à la place de l'iran 20 juillet
rens
quand c'est l'iran évidemment il faut
rester un peu rationnel via l'iran
respecté l'accord vous la faire
respecter l'accord cantonales tant qu'on
est sortis respecter l'accord
les états devront appliquer une petite
pression maximum ils ont
va j'ai l'économie iranienne pendant un
an l'iran à respecter l'accord entre
entre mai 2008 et mai 2010 heure en
demandant aux européens de faire quelque
chose les européens n'ont rien fait donc
face à l'iran a commencé un peu à
détricoter d'accord mais en disant à
chaque fois je crois qu'il a rappelé
écoutez les états unis reviennent de
l'accord tout de suite non revient tout
de suite dans l'accord donc ce que
demande l'iran c'est le respect du droit
international quand même 7 cet accord
2015 était validée par une résolution
des nations unies
donc le respect du droit international
je pense que bayonne rappelle tout le
temps qu'il est sensible au droit
international c'est que les états unis
reviennent dans l'accord qui n'aurait
pas dû quitter et annule toutes les
sanctions qu'ils ont mis en place donc
c'est vrai c'est pas effectivement
l'iran mais la russie en matière de
négociation mais ce que lol en terme de
leurs deux manches je pense qu'ils
demandent le respect du droit
international ni plus ni moins est ce
que on peut s'attendre avec le le poids
de ces sanctions américaines ne sont que
s'attendre à ce que
est-ce que l'iran tienne longtemps parce
qu'on sait que il y a quand même de gros
problèmes et économique dans le pays oui
mon avis c'est un peu se tromper si on
croit que justement c'est une erreur de
l'un d'eux tandis qu'american général
depuis longtemps de ne pas et où sur les
sanctions
on voit bien que basé tout sur les
sanctions sans stratégie diplomatique
il n'y a pas de ya pas de solution si il
ya eu un accord en 2015 c'est que barack
obama et ça lui a coûté des critiques
aux états unis a mis en place une
stratégie diplomatique et a dit dès le
début aux iraniens par exemple
pourraient enrichir de l'uranium
donc une potiche qu'avec eux des
sanctions l'iran résiste évidemment ça
leur coûte très cher et l'économie est
en pleine crise mais la notion de
résistance est au coeur de l'idéologie
de la république islamique d'iran et
notamment chez les plus durs donc ça ne
mène à rien s'ils voulaient cette
politique de pression et c'est pour ça
que je pense que dans ces négociations
je angela merkel dit oui il ya un
équilibre à trouver
il faut absolument que les américains
fassent des gestes pour lever je suis
pas toutes les sanctions mais une partie
des sanctions que les iraniens
comprennent que ok les amis
interviennent dans l'accord et ils sont
en train de lever les sanctions je crois
que croit ni à 10 qui lève les sanctions
graduellement ou d'un coup c'est on est
d'accord mais il faut il faut qu'il se
passe quelque chose du côté de la levée
des sanctions a mené trouver une
solution mutuellement acceptable c'est
ce que va chercher à obtenir raphaël
aussi directeur général de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
lors de sa visite en aujourd'hui est ce
que c'est possible et ce qui peut
empêcher un désengagement des
engagements qui est prévue demain sur la
fin des visites oui c'est pour ça que je
pense que franchement la lustration bayh
dole je pensais bien que mal d'années
qui revenait d'un accord lampant qu'on
peut penser qu'il ya eu quand même du
retard de prix les américains avaient
l'air de dire bonne on nous enlève pas
les sanctions on s'inquiète pas et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont pris conscience
que ça devenait grave et que les rangs
étaient été sérieux parce que c'est une
loi faut rappeler un set cet arrêt de
l'inspection des de l' agence
internationale fia tome x en fait c'est
une loi qui a été votée en décembre 2020
donc c'est pas nouveau suite suite à
l'assassinât du scientifique iranien et
les le parlement iranien dans cette loi
disait si les américains ne lève pas les
sanctions en janvier février on
appliquera cette loi donc c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau donc
l'impression que les gens se réveillent
un petit peu tard
donc là effectivement
le je pense que l'iran met effectivement
met la pression mais met la pression
pour que le droit international soit
respecté
donc là je pense que j'ai compris qu'il
va y avoir une réunion avec les cinq que
ça pour la première fois avec les états
unis donc ceux qui ont signé l'accord
moi je vous dis je pense que la clé
c'est vraiment ça il faut que les
américains donnent des signes qui sont
prêts à lever les sanctions les les
gestes qu'ils ont pris là comme rétablir
la liberté de circulation des diplomates
iraniens vous est à venir ok mais tu es
le coeur du problème c'est ça c'est les
sanctions américaines et notamment les
exportations de pétrole iranien
si on voit des exportations pétrole
iranien recommence un petit peu augmenté
je pense que les iraniens vont
comprendre le message et ils vont
commencer à prendre des mesures pour
contrer merci beaucoup
thierry coville merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris spécialiste de l'iran
merci à vous